[Music]
oh my god Khloe Kardashian and Kylie
Jenner sat down with Tyler Henry on
Wednesdays Hollywood media where the
sisters got warnings about their lives
and loved ones I think it's an honor to
have a reading from him first
Tyler helped Chloe connect with her late
father Robert he's coming through and
basically acknowledging that you've had
to take on or compensate some
responsibilities that your sisters might
or shouldn't may be done mm-hmm and
you've been left with having to do them
to hear that my dad acknowledges that I
take on more of a load that means a lot
to me Tyler also alerted Chloe to keep
an eye on her health I'm seeing skin.i
referencing to well looks like melanoma
I am susceptible to skin cancer I've um
I've had it twice before but
everything's fine and I get checked
every three months and when it comes to
romance Tyler told Chloe to spend as
much time with her man Tristan Thompson
so long as we can make sure distance
does not end up being an issue mm-hmm
perfect and he told Kylie to keep a
healthy distance from a past love
there's a situation with an individual
from the past we've been romantically
involved with and I basically through
this individual kind of going in and out
we want to really set healthy boundaries
and say no you can't kind of dip your
toes in and leave when you want
[Music]
you